we've got some updates on final fantasy
16. rambo is coming to mortal kombat
and valeran's new agent is a healer i'm
lucy let's get into it
[Music]
so final fantasy 16 might not be years
and years and years away
apparently the game is further along in
development than we thought
square enix says the game's basic
development is already complete
per a job recruitment page we have
already completed basic development and
scenario production
and are continuing to create large-scale
resources and build boss battles
while expanding our various development
tools also
most of our staff are carrying out their
work remotely
now we don't actually know what basic
development means in this context
but based on the quote it seems the
game's basic outline is locked in with
the developers now working on all the
little details
that finalize the game so yes we may not
have a release date for final fantasy 16
but as long as i don't have to wait for
five years like i did with final fantasy
vii remake then
i'll be happy that's right rambo is
coming
to mortal kombat 11. developer
netherrealm revealed the combat pack 2
for mk11
and it includes molina rayne and most
notably
rambo the trailer shows him walking out
of the jungle and firing his signature
machine gun
and yes that's right you heard correctly
he is voiced by sylvester stallone
rambo joins mk 11's growing list of
guest characters
that include the t800 from terminator
and robocop
mk11 is available right now on current
gen consoles and it's coming to next gen
with a free
upgrade cross gen cross play try saying
that three times fast
will be available starting november 17th
and valorent revealed their latest agent
a healer named skye
skye is an initiator from australia and
the trailer shows some animal trinkets
that she seems to use to track
and control enemies she's also seen
healing her teammates in a brand new
trailer
she'll be added to the game alongside
the 1.11 patch on october 27th
now a data miner allegedly leaked skye's
full kit and you can check out those
details over on gamespot.com
tomorrow on generation next jordan tam
and i go through all the breadcrumbs of
information that sony have been giving
us over the last week
about the playstation 5. make sure to
tune in on youtube.com
gamespot to watch i'll see you then